so the first thing we want to know is
whether consumers seek out Fairtrade
certified products in the marketplace in
order to test that we took Fairtrade
certified coffee we labeled it as
Fairtrade certified in one set of stores
we labeled it with a placebo label that
had no ethical component to it in the
other set of stores and we observed what
happens to sales as consumers are making
their day-to-day purchases in these
stores and what we found was that sales
increased by 10%
a remarkable margin given the
competitive competitiveness of the
industry under the Fair Trade Certified
label the second main finding that came
from the study is that if once we raised
the prices on the Fairtrade certified
coffee sales actually continued to grow
there was a positive price that asta
City but this was only true for one of
two Fairtrade certified coffees that we
tested for the less expensive coffee and
the sales actually decreased
dramatically and so that suggests to us
that there's two segments in the market
there's consumers who are willing to
support the price increases that come
with Fairtrade certification but they're
also consumers who will not support this
and they know it's about an equal split
I think the main takeaway is that their
substantial support for Fairtrade
certification in the marketplace today
but it's not unlimited so I think there
is a fair segment a fairly sizeable
segment that is not willing to pay more
for these ethically made product as much
as we might want to but there are like
there is a fair they lock share of
consumers that are willing to pay more
for these products and that's something
that you know companies I think can take
as an important lesson I mean I think
that this this gives you an opportunity
to differentiate your product from your
competitors and to really like you know
have I think there is a business case
for these ethical differentiation
schemes where you basically try to pass
on some of these costs for ethically
upgrading your supply chains to the
consumers I think the lesson that comes
from our experiment is is that this is
something that you should look into
seriously you should look into whether
you can ethically differentiate your
product cuz there are consumers out
there depending on the market that
you're in that are really willing to
reward you and who might on the other
hand punish you if you don't go down
this road it might be singled out as the
company that's kind of left behind while
other new competitors are ethically
upgrading you're not doing that and and
so I think there's a risk in to not
considering these schemes into not
thinking about you know what can I do to
produce my products in a way that it's
environmentally more friendly that is
sort of ethically more sustainable and
that has a better impact on the planet
which are things that we all care about